Cái gì nào emuted?
Thôi em toi ghi hôn, ngồi không lãi vопас nó v 6000halb bòo ng viringer.
Thôi em toi ghi hôn Đăng Ghi hôn và ghi hô sạy đầy vô.
Theo thủ Mỹ đồ năng ngạy bác nga trong đồzersu bắt đầu bởi với tôi.
Thôi em toi ghi hôn, dưới môi đồzeru bắt đầu bắt đầu bắt đầu bắt đầu bắt đầu.
Thôi em toi ghi hôn, dưới mắt đầu bắt đầu bắt đầu bắt đầu bắt đầu bắt đầu bắt đầu.
và hôm nay, bây giờ, hôm nay, lời lòng quy định thì thực và đã tẹn trên về mật điều tiêu chung.
Chúng ta sẽ gủ chuyên môn của anh, phân hồi lại lời gánh bảo, thì nhạc chang.
Tụi từng anh kia xa tâm ở khẳng định sẽ là thiếu công quan,
đều phó lời chúng quốc, nhìn mạnh đây là nên kinh tế lần thứ 2 thế giới,
và việc hợp tác lập cần thiết, vì lời có ra.
Tụi từng anh cho biết là đồn đã thông bảo chứ với Mỹ về chuyên thăm,
và hẳng định quan hệ anh Mỹ vẫn chặt chảy, mất chặt tụi đời hợp tác anh trong
Truy công dù, cũng sắp mơ dễn ra trong một cạnh chỉ thu công đàn,
đàn tìm các tụi đời tăng cho kinh tế,
có kảy chết có thể với chúng quốc là một phân trong trên lượng đà giá hòa đưa ta,
chân lập trường, khởi qua khó lường từ tổng thống Mỹ đồn trăm,
khiến ông sắp mơ đàn thăm theo 2.